i was willing in order to become an
equity analyst
at jennison associates i was willing
to buy into ideas that nobody wanted
even if we go through a correction and i
i ex
i expect one uh we must all almost
always expect corrections uh i i just
have to keep my eye on the prize
i think it's a good thing for the
ecosystem that um
that that understanding is look for the
leverage that's where your weak link is
need motivation watch a top 10 with we
believe nation
top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best kathy wood
and my take on her top 10 religious
success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one build a track record
asset management and finance generally
is a great place for women especially
if you a woman or anyone it's a man or a
woman
can develop a track record no one can
take my track record
from me better for better or worse you
know some years have not been so great
uh but no one can take it away from me
and
and if you build one over a long enough
period of time
uh and uh and are
are successful um it's usually a ticket
to more success
so i i always say try
and figure out a way to measure your
success in a way that
you know no one can take it away from
you and that does not mean
not being a team player being a part of
a team that develops
a great track record is really important
rule number two have a perspective what
do you think has been the biggest
determinant
or the biggest contributor to your
success
oh well i've had incredible mentors
i i don't think you can do it without
mentors uh
art laffer six sigalis
bob keiter lulu wong tanya modik
i think beyond that though because of
how i started in the industry i started
with economics so big picture
needed perspective and i was willing
in order to become an equity analyst at
janice and associates
i was willing to buy into ideas that
nobody wanted
i think that's a big part of success
generally so when i started
following equities sigalis bless his
heart gave me the opportunity
i wanted to grow in the business and he
said but i'm not going to
take any stocks away from our seasoned
analysts
you're gonna have to find your own so as
like a little dog
under the table look at her scraps and i
really mean that
uh and so reuters and telerate
and vodafone nobody wanted those stocks
uh they certainly didn't want the
foreign ones at that time
we were the u.s was where the action was
and database publishing reuters telerate
database publishing
tech analysts didn't want it because it
wasn't pure database publishing analysts
didn't want it because it wasn't
pure publishing and i'm saying i'll take
that and of course what happens
that was the precursor to the internet a
very big idea so i learned very early
when when analysts and portfolio manager
strategists
dismiss out of hand something that seems
to have a kernel excitement of
excitement associated with it
you know go investigate that rule number
three invest
in disruptive innovation we believe that
there are
five innovation platforms evolving at
the same time
this has never happened in history you
have to go back
to the late 1800s to see three
innovation platforms evolving at the
same time
back then electricity telephone
and the internal combustion engine for
the 50 years through
1929 because of those innovation
platforms we experienced a booming
economy
and very low inflation we
see that happening with these five
platforms
which are already we believe for prime
time the five innovation platforms
upon which we base all of our research
are dna sequencing robotics
energy storage artificial intelligence
and blockchain technology these
platforms cut across
sectors they cut across geographies they
cut across
markets and importantly they
are converging with each other to spawn
new innovation
a really good example of that is
autonomous taxi networks what are
autonomous taxi networks or autonomous
vehicles
they are robots autonomous vehicles are
robots
they will be electric so they'll be run
by batteries
and transportation will be moving on to
the grid
and they are powered by artificial
intelligence
so those are three platforms converging
now just think about traditional
research departments
who's going to follow those stocks
these are platforms which cut across
sectors
and geographies only with a new kind of
research effort do we believe
the capital markets will fully be able
to
exploit these transformational
opportunities so we have
an open research architecture we
are sharing our research uh throughout
the world
especially on social media we are living
in the communities we're researching
rule number four focus on the prize it's
okay
to enjoy being a rock star even if it's
just for a moment right
you're enjoying potentially
life-changing
success um most certainly but i have
been around the block a few times the
track a few times
and whenever things have gone this well
for me uh usually there's a correction
around the bend and i want to gird for
it and protect it
and also prepare our investors for the
possibility and say
just keep some powder dry because what
we're looking at here are
long-term again exponential growth
trajectories
that uh they're not going to be stopped
uh you can't
stop progress uh and today when the
government tries to stock progress
uh well it usually fails and so
even if we go through a correction and i
i ex
i expect one uh we must all almost
always expect corrections uh i i just
have to keep my eye on the prize but i
i do want to warn uh investors that
you know in the investment world it's
not just straight up and to the right
you know we will have those corrections
so again we just keep our eye on the
prize we have a five-year time horizon
we are fully invested at all times which
is what we are supposed to be
but that doesn't mean that investors
shouldn't you know sometimes take a bit
of money off the table
and keep some powder dry also if you
want to have more self-confidence and
self-belief
i've created a special free program
called 254
because the sign says that it takes up
to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a habit
so what i'm going to do is send you an
unlisted video to your email
every day for 254 days for free
to help your confidence and self-belief
shift forward
the link to join is in the description
below when i get to a really good level
then it's like okay now we're going to
deal with this thing
loving yourself is the most powerful
thing we can do
everything we give out can help people
really
improve the quality of their lives rule
number five be
adventurous kathy you have a very unique
perspective yourself
in terms of where this this industry is
is going and positioning yourself for
success on that
what what advice would you give to young
people
starting off in investing
well i would first i would say
and consider the source here but first i
would say
um try and stay away from
anything that is benchmark sensitive i
don't think that's where the real
opportunity
is i think that i think that world is is
being populated by value traps and just
as i think the returns are going to be
disappointing
the second thing i would say is try and
associate yourself directly with some
performance
metrics so you can be measured
your performance can be measured and no
one can take it away from you
i i think that's very important if at
all possible
and we are moving into a world that is
um
evolving towards exactly that okay let
me
let me figure out the return on
investment here you know we think about
that with technologies but
i think that's going to be true when it
comes to human
capital so those and just
be willing to be adventurous and
when others are running away and it's
conventional wisdom
that something is not going to take off
take a closer
look at it and and see if you can find
any merit i'm not saying there will
always be but if there is merit as
others are dismissing the possibilities
that's where you're going to find great
success rule number six
take risks are you worried that as rates
go
up those stocks could come down uh
well i i do believe if rates were to
take a sharp
turn up that we would we would see
evaluation reset and our portfolios
would
would be prime candidates for that
valuation reset of course
i agree with you scott there will be a
valuation reset
there will be fear i'm sure and we will
use it to our benefit
concentrating our portfolio to our
highest conviction names
but i think longer term especially given
the the powerful growth
trajectories that the five innovation
platforms around which we
revolve all of our research uh that that
those trajectories are so powerful
uh that these multiples that they these
companies are going to grow into their
multiples a lot faster than most
investors are now expecting and so
that's a source of confidence for us
rule number seven look for the leverage
in the equities market over the years
i've always learned whenever i think
i can do no wrong watch out just walk
out
start start taking the risk off right
because it's too easy
that's what happened and there were too
many out there who had
net who were who were leveraged to that
extent
who had no idea what a boom a bear
market would do to them like
kill them they're dead uh now
i think the good thing that's happened
about that is
everyone knows leverages something you
really have to watch
and you know uh even in terms
of you know uh our future plans
uh we uh in terms of
using leverage in the crypto world um
you know i i know what to do i've i've
run hedge funds and and so forth but
it's very clear to me that the people
who were stuck
um i don't think they were the
sophisticated hedge funds they were
the uh individuals who uh
got hooked and then uh
you know began to believe they could do
nothing wrong and then
now are out of business i think it's a
good thing for the ecosystem that
um that that understanding is look for
the
leverage that's where your weak link is
and you can even
you can even say that in the various uh
crypto asset ecosystems they all
learned a little bit more the governance
on some of these is
excellent but they all learned a little
bit more about
you know how to adjust their governance
to look out for
that as a pain point as a potential pain
point and risk factor
rule number eight invest aggressively
right now kathy your etfs alone are
generating an
annualized run rate of 220 million
dollars in revenue and that doesn't
include
the other assets under management
how profitable is the business
well it has our business
is uh very profitable now but believe me
the blood sweat and tears that we left
in the early days it's a scalable model
so we had to pay for the infrastructure
in the early days
and we were quite the loss making
company
and i felt it acutely since i funded
uh most of it for the first three years
uh
and so uh but in those early days we
were investing aggressively
which is what we tell our companies to
do uh because we thought we would be
able
to scale and when we were and when we
were able to scale
we'd have the right talent in place uh
to scale and so we've done that and
uh and i'm very happy to say that we are
able to reward uh those who are making
us happen the team that's making this
happen
um and rightfully so so uh
in a way the the hedge fund model you
have
uh maybe fewer people
and less in the way of assets
uh and the same kind of profits uh
so we've done it a different way and now
we've shown it's possible
and uh and and we think it's a really
healthy way to go as well
rule number nine diversify skills we
have a diverse group of people
a very young group of people generally
mostly because they have one foot
in the new world their education uh
that their education gave them the
opportunity to experiment with crispr
cas9 you're you're not going to find
that in the traditional
analyst space out there so we have
engineers computer science
uh uh scientists and
mathematicians uh so quantitatively
oriented as well
and we've broken out their
responsibilities not by sector
or industry but by innovation platform
and the 14 technology so our setup is
very different from other research
departments
the diversity of the team uh
i do consider that part of our secret
sauce just
different points of view all of them
very hungry
and uh energetic and enthusiastic
and really wanting to be a part of
changing the existing world order
particularly financial services i don't
think any
one of them dreamed they would enter the
financial services industry
in fact some of them thought that was
the dark side of the world
and so i basically said to a few of them
look if you want to help change the
world and financial services
open up open architecture with research
move into social media and marketing
come join us come join us and if you
want to
also maintain
or remain at the leading edge of your
field of expertise
come to arc because that's where we want
to invest and that's where you're
where you will extend your network
broaden your reach
more than you ever dreamed possible and
so each of our analysts
is becoming i think it's they're beca
each is becoming a superstar
within his or her area of expertise
and and that's another thing that you
don't see in other financial services
they will let the portfolio manager or
director of research go out there and
talk on behalf of the firm
our analysts are out there on twitter
uh linkedin medium telegram any social
network
that will help them engage with and
become
a part of the communities they're
researching so
this is very interesting to to
people generally but especially young
people
where social media is part of their life
blood
unlike many uh of the rest of us out
there
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun a non-tech question
aliens what is the probability
that they exist versus not exist
wow i've never thought of that i have to
be open to almost
anything in terms of what i do okay
how would you work through trying to get
to some probability
i'd get brett our director of research
and our analysts together to say
let's think through this let's let's
think through this
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
what i think people are also missing
talk about inefficiencies
the opportunities that are being created
today are trillion dollar opportunities
i often say
i think that amazon is a trillion dollar
stock
it's 240 billion dollars right now
jeff bezos has said that amazon web
services
will be bigger than the retail uh
services uh at some point in the future
so right now it's at a 7.5 billion
dollar run rate
amazon web services the retail is nearly
a hundred billion
that's a long way to go what he doesn't
tell you is this is
going to be four to five times as
profitable
so we're talking about a 240 billion
dollar cap company
i really believe he owns he uh
amazon owns infrastructure as a service
others are trying to compete open source
is trying to compete with open stack
they're probably going to be two players
but amazon owns that space this is a
trillion dollar idea
i think people are missing that and what
they will and
and you can you can talk about 100 pe
this is probably
200 p e they've made very little money
over the years because they've
reinvested against these
fantastic opportunities and those
companies who have
not invested are not going to be the
winners
the companies that have been invested
that have these enormous multiple
seemingly right now
are going to be the winners
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there